welcome to CBS to spring on your
o'donnell with Gayle King and look the
roses here what your name is transfer
student here welcome to the new school
Jeong oh it's not so new I loved what
you said yesterday or Nora that it's
it's a new day yes it is a new beginning
with an old friend well I'm really happy
to be here for the new beginning
yeah thanks for welcoming me is this
your excited face because we are very
excited that you're here at the table
I'm working on my various faces I'm very
excited inside I've got to calibrate for
my excited face for the public but we
have to point out in the studio we've
had a picture of your mom here since the
show began your mom of course is Nancy
Dickerson who was a legend in this
business what do you think John cuz I
was thinking about her today actually
what do you think that she would be
thinking that you're sitting here at the
table with us well first she would want
me to sit up straight yeah and and ie
she'd be thrilled but you know she
started 1952 they told her she couldn't
go on air for eight years cuz only man
went on the air and people wouldn't take
it seriously if a woman did so as happy
as she'd be that I'm here she'd be
happier that you two are here so that's
the big deal we are really glad you're
here as we begin this new chapter in all
of our lives here at CBS this morning
somebody said it was our sixth
anniversary yesterday and somebody asked
me what did you guys do and I said we
got John Dickerson that was our present
so it's great we're very excited very
excited to have you here at the table
Thanks